Well that was generalization.
Even trickier than generalization is figuring out how to implement associations.
OO programming languages do not directly support associations so the OO
design process must choose the best means of implementing these associations.
Some of the factors you have to take into account, first off is directionality.
What this means is, if your program is going to need to interact with several
classes, is the direction of that interaction always in one particular way?
First A and then B or might you go in either way.
Second is cardinality.
That is for
particular instance of one class are there multiple instances in another class?
And third is the kind of access you will make into classes.
Sometimes these are called the CRUD properties.
Where C stands for create, that is how you going to create instances, R is for
read, that means are you just going to query or access the, the instances,
U is for update, that is, could you change the instances and D is for delete.
Depending on, which of these particular kinds of accesses and
how frequently they occur, it might particularly in
the performance area effect how you choose to implement them.
And finally as far as invariant maintenance is concerned,
okay associations often have invariance associated with them.
Like referential integrity constraints and
it's up to you as the designer and programmer,
to build your program in such a way that these invariants are maintained